Move on,
straight up,
move on,
forget them.
They are lying and they are
untrustworthy,
so move on.
Now,
sometimes this can be hard,
especially if they've somehow tied
themselves into your life,
especially like for instance,
you get the kids involved in a divorce
scenario,
you can't move on,
but you have to mentally move on.
You have to emotionally detach from that
human and that's hard to do because
obviously they were someone that you
trusted and the reason I know that you
trusted them is because they got to a
point where they were able to betray
your trust and destroy you so they they.
It's hard,
but the fact that they trust that you
trusted them,
the fact that you had that relationship,
that's even more reason to walk away.
It's even more reason to move on.
You've got to see them for
what they are,
and this is an important piece right
here.
This is an important piece,
is something I learned as a young lad
out there in the world.
That person is not who you thought they
were,
right?
They are not who you thought they were.
The idea that this person
was a trustworthy,
faithful companion is not true.
It is not true.
That person does not exist.
They didn't exist and they don't exist.
It was in your head.
It was in your head that this person who
is trustworthy and you the they were
everything you wanted them to be and
they were faithful,
commanded.
That is a lie.
They are not that person.
They have proved it.
They've proved it by their actions,
so
move on and at the risk of sounding
callous,
get over it,
get over it.
Do not dwell.
Do not dwell on to not dwell on on what
it was and don't dwell on what it could
have been.
You.
Who are you and guys go through bad
breakups.
You know it's.
I just thought we were going to say no.
Don't dwell on that.
Deal with what it is right now.
What that person is.
Deal with reality except reality and be
be thankful free album.
He thankful that you were able to learn
before you invested more into this
person.
Be Be.
Be Thankful that you found out when you
did that this person was a liar,
that this person was unfaithful,
is untrustworthy.
Be Be thankful
that you know it and you know it now
instead of later and you know what else
is going to make it a lot easier to get
over these situations is recognize that
there's plenty of people out there in
the world are trustworthy and that our
faith,
we're good people.
They're out there.
Go find one of them,
but
don't think that that person that you
had was the only one in the world.
They're not.
And you know what if that as sometimes,
sometimes people have a hard time making
that trust because they're so caught up
and they,
they,
they don't want to meet someone else
right away.
That's fine.
Start with yourself,
right?
Rely on yourself.
Trust yourself because we want.
When someone breaks our trust,
we,
we questioned ourselves too,
like we think are my judgments bad.
I'm not a good judge of human character
because I totally put my faith in this
person and look what they did to me.
So now we don't trust our.
So you've got to build that trust up.
You got to build that trust up back
again with yourself.
How do you do that?
Read
right?
Learn workout,
be alone.
It's okay to be alone.
Some people get freaked out when they're
alone.
It's okay to be alone.
It's okay.
There's no big deal.
Enjoy it.
Do something productive and build that
trust up in yourself.
You'll look back at a situation and
learn from it.
We do that.
It's an post operational debrief.
Oh,
you've put too much trust in somebody.
Cool.
They broke your heart.
All right,
Roger that.
Let's see.
What would the steps,
what should I have recognized?
How many times did I say will?
You know?
They didn't call me,
but it's probably just because their
phone was out of battery.
No,
once your phone runs out of battery
once.
Okay.
You don't let it happen again.
Right?
So you start seeing those red flags to
you,
the mistakes that you made,
and then look for them next time around
because you deal with people all the
time that they made mistakes.
The first run,
they go back and they make the same
mistakes.
The second run,
they go back and make the same mistakes.
That third rung,
that's when you got to start blaming
yourself on your situation.
That's why.
That's why I said you got to like build
a relationship with yourself.
You gotta learn yourself.
You've got to trust.
You've got to learn to trust yourself,
so spend some time doing that and
then when you go back and you start
dealing with people,
because that's what,
that's what you got to watch out for is
that you become a hardened criminal.
You don't trust anybody like you were
talking about cops.
You know sometimes cops have a hard time
because they're dealing with scumbags
all day long and it builds up this,
this mistrust of other people.
So you don't want to have that happen.
You want to be suspicious of people,
but you want to be able to build trust
once they proved themselves.
So take those small steps and start
build up
overtime.
Don't just jump in and give someone 100
percent trust out of the gate.
You don't know him,
don't know him.
You know,
back in the day,
back in the day when old hardcore bands
used to have this t shirt that just says
trust.
No one was like,
yeah,
that's legit.
Right?
You don't.
Don't go out of the gate with the big
trust on somebody with important stuff.
Don't do it.
But the good news is,
like I said,
there's plenty of people out there that
are good people that you give you.
Give all your trust to just take it slow
brother.
Feel crazy how you just explained that.
So simple and it makes total sense when
you're in the situation though,
you know,
like you can't just detach it.
Be like,
what are the red flags that I didn't
know?
You're too busy missing the person or
whatever,
your disaster,
but even
going and looking at pictures has to
work to get out the picture and stare.
I've seen guys do that.
I'm like,
Bro,
give me that.
Let me throw this away for you.
That's not going to help that person.
If that.
I was always to me was,
was explaining like,
listen
guys,
what she was.
No,
no,
she wasn't a.
That is a lie,
that person that you put put together in
your head that you've assembled in your
mind,
that person doesn't exist.
They don't exist.
The person that you dealt with was a
liar,
was unfaithful,
was a cheater.
That's the person,
the person who wasn't this person that
you're putting forth in your mind.
That person doesn't exist,
so stop,
but you don't understand the good time.
Yeah,
I know.
Here's the trick.
Okay,
so
if.
Okay,
that person will lie.
That part of the cheater and what I kind
of said there was like you don't
understand the good time.
That's a real part of it.
That's really it.
It's like,
sure they did this.
Sure.
She.
I'm a flats.
My tires when she gets measured,
all that,
but the good times we have are so good.
So it's.
It's,
it's proof that it.
It's not about the person.
It's not about the person that you can
see all the red flags and how they
mistreat you from time to time or they
you.
It's about yourself and how you're sad
now because of all these reasons,
but the trick comes with what one of the
tricks come with.
Um,
same thing I said about drinking where
it's your brain because it's like
chemicals when you bond with someone in
certain in certain ways.
And it's different from,
you know,
it varies from person to person,
but it's like,
I think it's like oxytocin or I don't
know,
something where it's,
it's it,
but yeah,
it's going to.
But you feel this bond with this
specific person.
That's why you have these feelings.
Even though this girl like lies to you,
you see her lying text messages on your
phone right now.
You're looking at him.
Meanwhile,
you still,
men still miss him.
It's a trick because it seemed like that
your emotional wellbeing is attached to
this person kind of thing.
Right?
And all the other stuff,
you just kind of ignore it.
So it just like,
I'm the same with drinking,
right?
Why know?
Consciously like,
I'm going to be hung over tomorrow.
I get anything done,
all this stuff.
Why do I want to drink so bad right now?
You know,
kind of thing and it's the same thing.
The chemicals in your brain are telling
you like this girl is essential for you.
You know,
for your wellbeing is not yet.
Oh,
that's the logic though.
That's a lie.
It's a tricky.
Listen to that.
Don't listen to your brain.
Listen to me that she's not essential.
That's all you bro.
I'm telling you.
But that's the logic.
Those chemicals are blocking.
I have seen so many situations where
guys are just in.
What's horrible is I'm sitting here
saying this,
it's.
You could be smacking someone in the
face telling them,
move on,
and they're not to listen to that too.
So you gotta make that decision.
Yeah,
that's,
that's it's hard.
And guys ruined their lives.
I mean the oldest due to the girls and
guys,
they ruined their lives,
you know,
with over somebody that is completely
abusive,
whether mentally or physically that just
completely abusive and they'll ruin
their lives for this person.
That per se,
in my mind,
I think it's because they build a
person,
they build a person on the framework of
reality.
They build a fantasy and they're in love
with that fantasy and they want to keep
it going.
Right?
It's a fantasy.
So stop and they get away ignore like
all the quona version for sure,
and they remember the good times.
Even if it's like like 10 minutes a
week,
they remember those good times.
They ignore the red flags
because of that,
that you know that trick,
that chemical trick in their brain and
so it reinforces that thing that they
built.
You know,
that fantasy that they built there.
It's true,
this big.
The reality is this big and look the
street and they just attached to it.
You ever see a friend or whatever
because I'm assuming you're in,
you've never been in this situation like
you ever had a friend where they're
really into it.
They're almost ruining their life.
They're in bad shape or whatever,
and then whether it be all of a sudden
or years later,
whatever they're thinking back in,
they're like,
whoa.
Was.
I think because the chemical trick so to
speak,
wears off,
and then they can see all of that logic
that you're talking about.
You're like,
oh my gosh,
man,
it's,
it's almost like,
it's almost like you feel like you were
a different person when you recover your
kids.
I mean,
just the fact that you can't talk any
sense into people when they're in that
situation is the trick.
You got to try and.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard,
but I think knowing that that's it.
It's a chemical in your brain that is
tricking you and it goes for a lot of
stuff.
Donuts,
like all this that's tricking you.
If you know like,
Hey,
and you say,
I'm not going to be tricked.
I feel it.
I feel this.
I feel the sadness.
I feel missing this person,
but it's a trick,
you know?
Yeah,
it helps.
It totally helps.
I like it.
So move on,
man.
I know it's hard.
Trust us.
Speaking of moving on,
next question,
unless we want to talk about this
anymore.
No,
I think you're ready to move on.
Exactly right.
Let's move on.
In what circumstances
do you recommend direct?
I will hold on.
Oh,
we're not going to be stuck on,
but what's horrible is been people
killed themselves in these situations
over a lie.
Yeah,
that's,
that's me.
That's the trick,
but it's a lie in guys or girls get so
distraught over this fantasy that
doesn't exist and what's really jacked
up is if they could just move on,
they'd find a reality that was actually
congruent with what their desires are.
It's out there.
You can see people all over the world.
They're there,
they're in relationships.
I having fun from every level,
right?
There's someone out there,
but you,
you get caught up in this mental trap
and,
and obsessing over a fantasy.
It's a fantasy.
Don't,
don't,
don't obsess over the fantasy,
man.
There's,
you can,
you can get over it and there's plenty
of other human beings out there that are
awesome.
So go find one of them,
and in the meantime,
hang out with your Badass self,
right?
Become a better person and working out
is a big one for sure.
For sure.
That's it.
That's the 100 percent.
Just get,
get into the gym and get after it.
Jujitsu solves everything.
Yes,
lifting solves everyday.